hey this is presh talwalkar
the following problem was given to
nine-year-old students in america
the calculation for a b multiplied by b
a
has the first row equal to 384
the second row equal to 2560
the sum of these is equal to the product
and that is 2944.
a and b are two different digits
find the value of a and b
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and keep watching to learn how to solve
this problem
[Music]
here is one way to solve the problem
focus on the calculation of a b
multiplied by a
this will correspond to the first row
that's equal to 384
what can we deduce from this
we can see that 10 a multiplied by a
plus the carryover of b multiplied by a
is equal to 380.
that means 10 a multiplied by a is
approximately equal to 380.
in other words a multiplied by a is
approximately equal to 38
so we can consider perfect squares
5 multiplied by 5 is equal to 25
that's too small
6 multiplied by 6 is equal to 36
and 7 multiplied by 7 is equal to 49
that's too large
the only possibility that works is 6
multiplied by 6 is equal to 36
so we can conclude that a is equal to 6.
we substitute that in and then we
consider we have a carryover that's
equal to 2 because 6 multiplied by 6 is
equal to 36 and the result is 38.
so we know
that b multiplied by six is equal to
four with the carry over of two
in other words b multiplied by six is
equal to twenty-four
that means b is equal to four
and we've solved the problem
we have a is equal to six and b is equal
to four
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you